c'était un rendez vous à ne pas manquer
pour ces étudiants ce vendredi une
trentaine d'élèves de l'université lyon
iii se sont rassemblés pour une
opération coup de poing l'objectif
montrer au gouvernement qu'ils sont tout
à fait capables d'étudier tout en
respectant les gestes barrière à
l'initiative de cette action laurine
porte parole du groupe facebook les
étudiants de la république
si pour elle les mesures annoncées par
emmanuel macron sont un premier geste
elle reste néanmoins insuffisante ça
montre aujourd'hui qu'on est capable de
faire la part des choses et qu'il faut
vraiment nous faire confiance parce que
au-delà du fait d'être quand même
l'avenir du pays et a peut être un peu
exagéré mais en fait à l'est pas puisque
on va travailler en train dé futurs
d'actifs et que bah il peut nous faire
confiance et à que l'avenir se prépare
aujourd'hui n'est que là bas on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir un avenir et nous
venons dû être reconnu une action
symbolique organisé en complément des
manifestations depuis ce mercredi les
étudiants se rassemblent dans plusieurs
villes de france pour dénoncer la
situation précaire dans laquelle ils se
trouvent durant cette crise sanitaire
manon étudiante lyonnaise passionnés de
musique a décidé d'exprimer sa
frustration en chanson sur l'air de la
bohème de charles aznavour
c
[Musique]
35e ces jeux
et puis et
[Musique]
c'est très dur émotionnellement pour moi
tout ce qui se passe en ce moment et du
coup je me suis dit pourquoi pas la
réécrire en version 2020 et 2021 avec
tout ce qui se passe et donc du coup
c'est venu comme ça et j'ai pu vider un
peu mon sac
grâce à l'écriture
vraiment je pense que ce qui est le plus
compliqué en ce moment de mon côté c'est
cette absence de liberté pensait liberté
qu'on n'a plus on peut plus sortir après
18 heures on ne peut plus aller dans les
cafés on peut plus aller dans les
théâtres etc
je trouve pour moi en tout cas que celle
plusieurs lors de son face à face avec
les étudiants dans l'essonne ce jeudi
emmanuel macron avait annoncé un jour
par semaine en présentiel pour le
deuxième semestre
insuffisant selon les principaux
concernés reste à savoir s'ils
obtiendront davantage du gouvernement
avant la fin de l'année universitaire en
cours